[Musik]
ja schlag
schlag 10 uhr ortszeit hier in moskau
schönen guten morgen aus dem moskauer
ard-studio druck ist mein name ich bin
korrespondentin hier in moskau ich
begrüße sie zur großen sieges parade die
wie jedes jahr hier in moskau
stattfindet am tag am tag des sieges der
sowjetischen armee über hitler
deutschland ist eine art wir sehen den
kommandierenden der parade der jetzt
seine truppen eine ehrenformation dem
russischen verteidigungsminister
präsentieren will
das hier ist zunächst der einzug der
russischen staatsflagge und das banner
des sieges
[Musik]
dieses banner das siegel sagt auf der
sprecher gerade ist das wichtigste
symbol dieses sieges das ist eine kopie
der original frage natürlich die wir da
sein die original frage hat über dem
reichstag gewählt 1905 die männer die
diese flaggen auf den rosenplatz tragen
haben das monat landet man glaubt es
nicht aber tatsächlich sind selbst für
schritt zahlen und die schrittlänge
vorgegeben
sie gehen 120 schritte in der minute
sowas muss man trainieren stechschritt
wie wir sehen sind 350 m
diese bei den platz gehen und das ganze
schaut zucker
[Musik]
dieser feiertag ist einer der in der
sowjetunion natürlich bereits gefeiert
wurde hier sehen wir den
staatspräsidenten putin
umgeben von veteranen putin hat diesen
feiertag neue bedeutung noch mal gegeben
zu sowjetzeiten wurde nicht in jedem
jahr eine parade abgehalten
das hat sich erst in den 90er jahren
geändert und seitdem präsident putin an
der macht ist
seit der jahrtausendwende wird diese
parade auch wieder mit militärischem
gerät begangen
[Musik]
wie sich der trainer brasiliens nicht
nur in moskau gibt es heute diese parade
sondern in vielen russischen städten in
28 wir stecken auch in den orten in drei
orten auf der animierten filmen die
eigentlich zur ukraine gehört aber von
russland seit 2005 über jason statham
spielt klasse
der primus linie s3 mediterrane
[Musik]
es sind keine ausländischen gäste heute
bei der parade zu großen runden
jahrestagen lädt man die 1 in diesem
jahr hat der kreml gesagt kann wer
willkommen man lade nicht besonders ein
bekommen ist nur einer das ist der
präsident von tadschikistan einer
ehemaligen sowjetrepublik wir werden ihn
sicher gleich auch ein publikum sehen
bereits im vorfeld hier bevor unsere
übertragung begann hat man viel darüber
geredet dass es dass es also dass der
familie rathmann heißt er dass er da ist
man ist ganz stolz darauf dass da
zumindest ein ausländischer gast
gewonnen
das ist ein extralob oft der der
armeegeneral der hier die parade
kommentiert und jetzt wird durch dieses
tor achten sie auf die inszenierung
perfekt gemacht der
verteidigungsminister kommen
dass er sich bekreuzigt ist ja doch eher
ungewöhnlich hier wird immerhin des
sieges der sowjetarmee gedacht eines
atheistischen staates aber das hat sich
geändert
[Musik]
da ist das sehr gut
verteidigungsminister auch schon seit
2012 mittlerweile als held russlands
wird er hier vorgestellt das ist sein
offizieller titel aus
[Musik]
die beiden fahren aufeinander zu in
diesen autos das sind übrigens autos
russischer produktion
august heißen die ihn früher machte man
das mal mit dicken westautos
mittlerweile fährt man die sogenannten
vaterländischen die man das hier nennen
die original parade 1945 als marschall
schukow für die truppen präsentierte die
fand auf erden statt
armee generals ali koc verkündet dem
verteidigungsminister dass die truppen
der moskauer garnison bereit sein für
die parade
und jetzt beginnt das abfahren diese
truppen wir werden das gleich vielfach
höheren der verteidigungsminister wird
den einzelnen truppenteilen die da
stehen jeweils vor zum sieg jahrestag
des sieges gratulieren und dann werden
wir ein vielstimmiges hurra höheren
mehrfach
[Musik]
nochmal zu sehr gut das ist einer der
beliebtesten politiker hier im land
bevor er verteidigungsminister wurde war
er minister für katastrophenschutz auch
so ein action ministerium wo man in
vielen aktionen bei rettungsaktionen
überschwemmungen großbränden und er
liegt regelmäßig auf den vordersten
plätzen hier in der beliebtheit
das ist ein mann im beliebt im volk so
ein typ mit anpackt image den mag man
hier sehr
[Musik]
00 10 02 die nummernschilder jetzt kommt
die gratulation
[Musik]
sowohl die riesch ließ das superbootcamp
schön
über ihn
souveränität nicht den effektiven ist
unsere die prämien
die usa
etwas über die spezifischen kosten ist
die das geht jetzt weiter von einer
gruppen abteilung zur nächsten
[Musik]
immer wieder zunächst die begrüßung dann
antworten die soldaten größten zurück
und dann kommt die gratulation mit dem
hurra
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die lieferungen
falls sie sich wundern wie die beiden in
001 und 002 in beiden autos so gerade
und sicher stehen können diese autos
haben eine haltevorrichtung ganz
unbemerkt in der mitte zwischen den
sitzen
mit der mit der linken hand in hand
halten sie sich dort fest und genau
hinschaut kann man das sehen wie gesagt
ursprünglich mal bei der allerersten
parade 1945 saßen verteidigungsminister
und kommentierender der parade auf
pferden
das hat danach aber meines wissens nie
wieder stattgefunden seitdem fährt man
auf
[Musik]
in deutschland gilt als tag der
kapitulation des endes von
hitler-deutschland der 8 hier feiert man
den neubau weil die kapitulation in der
nacht unterschrieben wurde in russland
war es zu dem zeitpunkt und in der
sowjetunion schon der neunte mal die
allererste parade hat übrigens nicht im
mai stattgefunden sondern erst ende juni
es hat eine zeit gedauert bis das die
kämpfer zurück waren von der front
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ohne papiere
die überbuchung distanz mit boris
trainiere mit ruhig wo ist über die
rumänische sich das waren jetzt die
luftlandetruppen den schäuble zum tag
des sieges gratuliert hat für viele
russen ist dieser tag ein ganz wichtiger
tag es gab gerade erst eine frische
umfrage viele halten ihn für den
wichtigsten feiertag im land
[Musik]
also viele bezeichnen ihn sogar als
wichtiger als den anderen großen
feiertag hier nämlich neuer und
silvester das ist sowas wie unser
weihnachten mit geschenken und
tannenbaum
aber dieser tag sagt eine mehrheit der
russen sei für sie noch wichtiger es
sind 27 millionen menschen umgekommen
sowjetbürger getötet nicht nur im kampf
sondern auch ermordet von deutschen
besatzern längst nicht alles russen ein
hoher blutzoll haben auch die ukraine
belarus bezahlt vor allem an zivile
bevölkerung und natürlich ist das hier
ein wichtiger wichtiger gedenktag für
die menschen auch bin und ist bis heute
weder hat wie man in der familie der im
quote kämpft hat gestorben ist gelegt
jetzt fährt der verteidigungsminister
richtung oberkommandierenden der truppen
und das ist natürlich russlands
präsident putin
[Musik]
er nennt ihn genosse oberkommandierender
und er gibt bekannt dass die truppen
bereits in putin wird jetzt reden
[Musik]
begrüßt alle bürger und bürgerinnen alle
soldaten und gratuliert ihnen zum backen
ein kolossaler historischer sieg wir
sind stolz auf die generation und
verdanken
diese heldentat sieg über den faschismus
habe vor allem der sowjetische volk ist
unser volk war vieler verschiedener
völker und religionen hätten sich
aufgerieben auf den feldern auf den
schlachtfeldern
putin und auch die unbeugsamen bürger
die ihre städte zu helden stärken
[Musik]
zeltstädte auf murmansk oder auch diese
städte und die fabriken in den städten
hätten die menschen an der front
unterstützt wie sie können ihn auch das
müsse gewürdigt werden auch die menschen
die blut gespendet hätten die menschen
die den evakuierten geholfen erzählt sie
als partisanen auch wenn die
kriegsgefangenen
wenn kinder väter mütter töchter seien
gestorben
alle dieser werde man hier gedenken und
eine schweigeminute
paralysiert
putin erinnerte daran dass vor genau 80
jahren in diesem jahr also in
deutschland stattfand
der feind hätte nicht nur das system
zerstören wollen sondern das volk alles
zu tun dem aufzuhalten und der stärke
der soldat gewartet hätten
in den lazaretten
1941 damals vor jahren hätten ja nochmal
blutige jahre vorgestanden und was
krieges nicht vergessen könne und auch
nicht verzeihen können
man müsse aus der geschichte lehren
ziehen aber nazismus die
geschichtsschreibung und das ist heute
wie beim menschen gebe die versuchen die
geschichte umzuschreiben und die täter
zu russland verteidigen das
international reichen aber immer auch
seine nationalen interessen als der
ruhige
müssten ein beispiel im volke der sieger
und dem großen sieg
eine emotionale rede vor den es immer
sehr emotional bei diesen reden mit an
weniger politik da werden wir später
noch darauf eingehen jetzt die hymne und
die salutschüsse
[Musik]
der junge jetzt stellt sich die
informationen auch auf jedem dieser
eingezeichneten punkte wert später ein
soldat stellen und das ist der beginn
der eigentlichen parallel logo
sämtliche russischen kanäle übertragen
diese parade
man kann sicher sein dass jeder hier im
land irgendwo in mexiko
da wird noch einmal der kommandierende
dieser parade vorgestellt projekts
salopp auf den haben wir eben schon mit
dem verteidigungsminister gesehen
es ist für uns ein wenig befremdlich
diese faszination mit den neuen features
bietet thomas koops chor aber jeder
hatte eine mini generation an qualität
verlieren gehört barbara stamm
manche eine gute schulische das moses
basilika alexander gemacht die juli
musikers bei rot über das einschicken
das system ist bewusst
der film wie diesem an gesucht wird die
parade immer von den trommlern einer
kadettenschule muss man irgendwie druck
des westens gegen präsident michael a es
gibt wirklich ein weltkrieg sein und
vielleicht auch ihre reise aus 50.000 in
russland und in den anderen ehemaligen
sowjetrepubliken
aber es gibt natürlich noch sehr viel
mehr die den krieg erlebt haben durch in
gelitten haben oder in irgendeiner form
beteiligt waren ihm den sie in den
fabriken gearbeitet oder menschen die
als kriegsgefangene oder als
zwangsarbeiter zum beispiel in
deutschland könnten noch an die
hunderttausend seien auch da gibt es
unterschiedliche schätzungen profi
alexander sims art
es gab allerdings auf eine zahl der
russischen statistikbehörde demnach im
vergangenen pandemien fast 40.000
menschen genau dieser generation
gestorben
[Musik]
wir verraten aber der schotter liegt
aber ich werde das was peter gegangen
aber in der schule richtlinie wird nicht
so doof ist ausbildung in das schulleben
soldaten gesprochen schlafen beim
publisher die krasse bushido war dabei
das tor von ska
und da gehen jetzt wie kommen eigentlich
zu ihnen gehören von russland annektiert
läuft hier selbstverständlich mit aus
russischer sicht gehört sie zurückhaben
[Musik]
das stimmige chablais die jemals vor
madagaskar aber das allein
[Musik]
daher ist es mir schwer sowohl das
gesuch 30 juni in die jugend
militärorganisation die jung arm jahr
wird angeführt von einer jungen frau die
die beste sei in den verschiedenen
disziplinen wird hier angekündigt dass
man die quote wohl gut hin das kann man
so sagen hat die gesellschaft durch
stärker militarisierte spielt eine sehr
viel größere rolle als noch vor 20
jahren
das militär militärische ausbildung
allein auch der stellenwert dieses tages
war natürlich ein ganz wichtiger
gedenktag ist und den man hier
ich kann mich noch erinnern an die
ausgebildete millionen in den anfang der
90er jahre den mann damals etwas anders
dann hat man natürlich geld warten
paraden statistik nicht mehr das hat er
abgeschafft das war immer eher ein
feiertag der bittersüß war man war
traurig und beklagte die vielen
kriegstoten und man da auch gleichzeitig
schuldig und freute sich über den sieg
in den letzten jahren ist noch mal
wieder stärker das militär und auch team
und vor allem die militärische stärke
für morgen feiert im wenig sein
charakter gehört immer noch der zug zu
trauern und die freude über den sieg zu
zeigen aber wenn es ist auch sehr viel
an ihm und demonstration militärischer
stärke zu sowjetzeiten gab es auch
ehrlich so eine parade sondern nur an
den großen jahrestagen 20 jahren wurde
und die militärakademie coach erst ohne
von jrr tolkien die privilegien die
armee steht bereits
[Musik]
doch mal fast jede familie im land hat
jemanden 27 putin hat in seiner rede
noch mal auch darüber gesprochen er hat
muss man in die nachfolge der sowie
zusammengestellter ganz klar immer
wieder von unseren golfsport um so von
den vielen eltern die auch mit gekämpft
haben aber er sieht sich schon als
nachfolger sind viele andere jetzt
selbstständige staaten ebenso heilig und
betroffen
wie gesagt auf dem bild haben eine
solche zeit aber viele viele sowie
kämpfer aus anderen orten in kasachstan
[Musik]
sehen soldatinnen in russland gibt es
berz nicht aber dennoch gibt es frauen
bei der armee in den rollen die man
früher als klassisch weiblich ansah
[Musik]
wie gesagt frauen in der armee aber es
ist geschafft die ausrangierte deutsche
anleger die die republik immer die story
ohne risiko dass du eine lockere so eine
gier ist als großer user seiner
regierung hat zudem auch über geschichte
geredet und das war ein mensch leicht
haben sie das bemerkt wurde der sehr
emotional und wurde
sehr sehr bestimmt plötzlich in der
stimme er hat quasi gesagt dass es
versuche geben die geschichte
unterschreiben damit meint er zum
beispiel polen aus russischer sicht ist
mit schuld am ergebnis des krieges an
seiner eigenen teilung und auch die
balken hätten sich aus russischer sicht
ja freiwillig der sowjetunion
angeschlossen das ist natürlich aus der
jeweiligen sicht der länder hat sich
völlig anders stellt sich völlig anders
da eine art von eigener
geschichtsschreibung angekündigt und
setzt sie auch durch
es gibt ja eine verfassungsänderung in
russland eine sogenannte verfälschung
der geschichte ist jetzt also da erleben
wir schon auch noch mal eine
eine art besondere sicht russlands auf
sich selbst und auf seine rolle in der
geschichte
[Musik]
dieser tag ist unter den auch zu einer
art identitäts symbol des russischen
staates ein segen war für ganz europa
aber dieses gedenken und die eigene
rolle in diesem krieg und wiesen sie
zurück wohnen das ist dass das ist so
eine art nicht sagen gründungsmythos
aber schon ist ein ganz wichtiger
identität stiften moment im europäischen
sinn verstehen
das war immer schon einen ganz wichtigen
moment aber dieser winter putin ist
dieser aspekt ganz mit
cool wie cordula balke bei bier sehen
wir werden alles geben was gut wie gut
ihre mutter das problem ist
kuba einsah dass hier vor der linie war
es gibt kein dienst sie sehen die
geringelten hinten das
sind tatsächlich standard unterhemden
der russischen armee die gibt es blau
weiß und den rot weiß wie gehören zur
uniform der russischen armee sogenannten
pony asti es gab mal eine zeit lang
seine bewegung so eine art hippie
bewegung wo man die dinge auch so trug
und das war dann total hipp und an
gesagt dass ich wieder vorbei aber wenn
sie darauf achten so werden wir das
unter vielen uniformen sind
[Musik]
unser video erklärt rudi können die
spezialisten
[Musik]
dass die der so in reih und glied
marschieren ist natürlich nur sache von
ganz lange übung manch jahren monatelang
geübt und jetzt diese parade gab es also
auch über wochen vor den toren moskaus
in einem auf einem nachgebauten gelände
das im gruppenplatz ähnelt geprobt
worden es gab dann auch zu üben und eine
große generalprobe in der stadt abadan
moskau in der nacht fand das meistens
stadt weiträumig in der innenstadt
abgesperrt
ich bin dann irgendwann mal spätabends
nach hause gegangen nach einer späten
schicht und bin auch einer ganzen parade
von panzern begegnet also das natürlich
[Musik]
die blauen die bäder grad seien die
blauen mir zu lande truppen
wir haben einen eigenen feiertag der ist
ganz moskau voll mit menschen ehemaligen
und aktiven mitgliedern der
luftlandetruppen die mit blauen kappen
dann durch die gegend ziehen über das
schloss mit plus dabei gesagt wie sie
[Musik]
mit alex mio
weil sie sich die frage stellen wie es
eigentlich um corona steht in russland
wir sehen hier ja keine masken
so ist das eine schwierige und auch die
antwort darauf ist schwierig wir haben
im vergangenen jahr erlebt dass die
parade verschoben wurde sechs wochen
weil die krone zahlen so hochbahn sie
wurden die frau wurde dann ende juni
abgehalten
heute allerdings so die zahlen höher als
damals wie heute war aber gar keine rede
mehr davon dass man irgendwie
verschiebbare gerade wird stattfinden
wir gehen davon aus dass die teilnehmer
hier alle geimpft sind
putin selbst ist ja auch zumindest heißt
es dass man hat das nicht gesehen aber
es wurde irgendwann verkündet hat lange
gedauert man hat sich gewundert warum
hat es uns firma russland hat ja seinen
eigenen impfstoff entwickelt aber es hat
dann doch
ein halbes jahr gedauert nach
entwicklung des impfstoffs so ist ja der
selbst aufgetan hat russland am
stärksten betroffenen staaten das
korruptionsrisiko seit beginn der
pandemie gibt es offiziell 120 tausend
tote oder werbungskosten
wir wissen aber auch dass russischen
staatlichen amt für statistik eine über
sterblichkeit von mehr als 400.000
[Musik]
ursache wird auch bewusst raster der
kunde ist tatsache ist es hat sehr sehr
viele opfer gegen auch nach offiziellen
zahlen
[Musik]
krasniqi lieber in das russische duo
die eisenbahn hat eigene truppen
marschieren jetzt gerade die der
russischen eisenbahn
[Musik]
dies muss solche
oder holt polizei warum so möchte sie
das ist minuten bedeuteten platz hat war
ihm ein polizist gehen und das duo
bauherr erzbistums in dieser region ihre
[Applaus]
sehkraft mit politischen oder
historischen der polizei sagt der
sprecher gerade werde auch außerhalb der
grenzen russlands
[Musik]
da war super das hat dem effektiven chef
der kommunistischen partei gesehen mit
der schwarzen katze diese bahnhof
stellen in den ausländischen ehrengast
den präsidenten tadschikistan habe ich
noch nicht gesehen da saß gegen inmitten
von häufig vertreter einzelner regionen
russlands im letzten jahr bei der großen
jubiläums parade saß aus jeder region
einen veteranen mit guten auch der töne
die mussten alle vorher zwei wochen in
quarantäne
jetzt nehme ich an sind auch alle gehen
[Musik]
das sag ich jetzt ein paar obwohl ich
nicht weiß ob sie es nicht doch wissen
aber ich werde oft danach gefragt sind
kein volk kosaken sind einfach eine eine
das ist eine lebensform und eine eine
einstellungssache also sachen sind
menschen die früher im auftrag der zarin
die weiten sibiriens übertragen auch
jetzt sehen sie sich als militär obwohl
sie formal nicht
nicht so weit ich weiß zumindest nicht
bestandteil der musik wie sie es liebt
bella bruder so ist so verrückt war hier
über disco
er war steinig jedoch nicht gefasst
[Musik]
russland hat übrigens fast zu viele
soldaten wie die nato etwa dreieinhalb
millionen 3 millionen in 300.000 davon
sind etwa eine millionen aktiv die
anderen reservisten aber das sieht bei
der nato auch nicht viel anders aus
[Musik]
es ist natürlich eine große ehre hier
mitlaufen prof es werden nur die besten
ausgesucht
[Musik]
wie gesagt monatelange vorbereitung eine
erinnerung fürs ganze leben familien
sind stolz auf ihre söhne und vereinzelt
auch töchter die mir mit marschieren
dürfen
[Musik]
mir hat mal einer erzählt dass er es
gehasst hat die selbst vorbereitung
wirklich unheimlich schwierigen übungen
bis da alle wirklichen reingekriegt
gehen aber der moment als er dann taten
k2 dann ein ganz erhebender glücksmoment
gewesen wie im rausch verflogen
und ich denke das ist für viele männer
das hing wie gesagt auch damit zusammen
wie viele stellen werk im militär und
allen militärischen im volk gegeben wird
wie wenig auf und kritisiert
da waren durchfall hat man dann bei
kubicki muss sagt polizist fällig
[Musik]
nico war schon ist alias kommissar user
positive company coaching hat mädchen
über so ein hero ist sind jetzt großer
jubel unter sehen der zweite teil der
parade kurz bevorstehen wir haben gerade
gesehen dass da rechts neben sie im
historischen museum da sehen wir auf den
weg zum roten platz hinter das in
zunächst mal weltkriegs panzer soweit
ich das sehen kann
aber russland wird hier natürlich auch
seine neueste waffentechnik präsentieren
dieser weg den die panzer nehmen ist
nicht der historische der historische
geht an der anderen seite des dieses
roten gebäudes vorbei links des
historischen museums aber den hat jens
hinzu gestellt mit einer kleinen kapelle
weil er keine panzer auf dem roten platz
mehr böse unter putin haben sie einen
anderen weg gefunden und sind wieder
teil der parade
[Musik]
quadratmeter
die jost ag
täglich registrieren
aber das ziel
ich wollte hier freude juni peggy sirota
von krasniqi die prägung ist jetzt
definitiv
[Musik]
das darin dass bestimmte war wie
skicross muss man da kann man doch nicht
wirklich diese mutanten geht im juni
defizite sind diese ps da sind die t 34
panzer die panzer die wohl
kriegsentscheidend waren für diese
version den wehrmacht panzern hoch
überlegen einfach zu bauen für
massenproduktion geeinigt geeignet diese
t 34 panzer werden hier verehrt es gibt
spielplätze mit mit nachbauten es gibt
karussells mit kleinen t 34 panzer in
jedes kind kennt diese panzer die
eröffnen natürlich die kann
[Musik]
sabine fischer 35 uhr
the world away
schützenpanzerwagen taifun neueste
modelle hier zeigt russland natürlich
auch seine exportschlager das muss man
dazu sagen
jedes jahr gibt es irgendeine neuigkeit
zu sehen die militärexperten der ganzen
welt schauen jetzt sehr gewandt tun was
wir denn hier zu sehen bekommen
in port elizabeth projekt über z-wave
vor dem poker
[Musik]
russland ist einer der größten
waffenexporteure verkauft gut die
behörde sagt ein sehr erfolgreiches
abgelaufenes jahr gehabt seinen verkauf
seiner waffen
kunden sitzen nicht nur im nahen
mittleren osten nordafrika sondern auch
china kauft indien kauft und wie wir
wissen ja zb auch das nato mitglied
türkei werden sich hier gleich noch die
flugabwehrraketen seen as 400 die türkei
zum ärger der amerikaner und der nato
hier in russland gekauft
[Musik]
er wurde
da brüche gegangen und dann habt ihr was
in diesen gebieten
[Musik]
was wird weitere schutzgebiete alexander
fisher wurde am pc
das britische sci profitieren
premiumpresse politik war die
demonstration dann gibt's in die usa
die thüringer sind armada
[Musik]
die neuesten russischen panzer d14
armada da gibt es jetzt auch ganz frisch
eine exportversion hybrid hier natürlich
auch fahren und der mann der wie
calexico war
die division usa durchschnitt regiert
mit publik softies comeback im märz war
die sg agierte aber das ist auch zu
einem exportschlager ist kann der
russischen raketensysteme geeignete
mittel und langstrecke oder für kurz und
mittelstrecke die sind zum beispiel in
kaliningrad stationiert den nato
soldaten die dort ihren stationiert sind
und es kann der ist auch verlegt worden
an die an die ukrainische grenze jetzt
kürzlich bei der großen drücken
verlegung der russischen also eine
kleine drinnen geste gegenüber der
ukraine werden sie und vielleicht auch
den sieger erlebt was wir fordern ist
ruhig gebieten wieniawski was diese
brigade oder doch
liegen
jede kameraeinstellung ist hier
natürlich auch zigfach geübt das ist
schon sehr beeindruckend natürlich nicht
auf den panzern kameras zum teil auch
fliegende kameras haben wir eben schon
gesehen
das ganze ist ein spektakel das sich
natürlich ans eigene volk richtet aber
auch an die möglicherweise
interessierten im ausland die vielleicht
auch an diesen waffen interessiert
die soldaten die teilnehmen hier sind
übrigens alle wie es heißt auf
freiwilliger basis geben
das hatte ich ihn eben noch vergessen zu
erzählen insgesamt ist das im
bewusstsein oder die impfbereitschaft
eher niedrig in russland ist wächst so
langsam seitdem auch putin sichert
engine lassen aber es ist immer noch
eine eine eine knappe mehrheit der
russen die überhaupt darüber nachdenkt
sich immer verlassen
die mehrheit geimpft vollständig sind
bislang überhaupt erst acht prozent
obwohl russland ja seitdem mit den roten
köpfen die belgrad gesehen haben das
sind denke ich mal wieder sind die box
systeme auch ein bug system ist ja sie
hat traurige berühmtheit erlangt weil es
nach den ergebnissen der internationalen
ermittlungsbehörde über der ukraine das
malaysische fahrzeug im h 17
abgeschossen
und das hier vielleicht die letzte waffe
die ich in vorstelle ohne selber ist
richtig viel darüber zu wissen panzer
sind rose flammenwerfer große sachen die
wirklich große hitze erzeugen können und
die den schaden angerichtet haben sind
zb ebenso wie die sortierung die windows
pc
diese risiken oder gärtner sv hutthurm
ii oder an der esel zu
komplexer spd die über die hutschnur
russland heute ein richtig großer
feiertag man wünscht sich alles gute zum
sieg man beglückwünschen sich
gegenseitig es wird auch in familien
gefeiert
vorher ging man nach dieser parade in
die parks der stadt und traf dort
veteranen schenken blumen überreichte in
die fähnchen kleine rote fähnchen ganz
von herzen kommen sehr ernst gemeint
das wird natürlich weniger weil es immer
weniger veteranen heute ist leider in
moskau auf das wetter nicht so richtig
gut unter 10 grad in diesem regen
ich weiß nicht ob der stattfinden wird
es wird sicher heute später am abend
noch ein großes feuerwerk geben das gibt
es übrigens in 300 städten im ganzen
land feierlichkeiten auch wenn sie keine
parade machen so machen sie doch
feierlichkeiten mit blasorchester auf
dem auf dem marktplatz und mit einem
feuerwerk am abend denn man erinnert und
gedenkt dieses tages mann hat in jedem
ort noch irgend jemanden der den krieg
erlebt hat und er wird dann geehrt und
gefeiert veteranen gehen auch in die
schulen wenn sie noch können und reden
mit den kindern also nochmal dieser tag
ist der wichtigste feiertag für das volk
hier sicherlich auch weil es ein
bisschen befördert wird aber doch auch
weil es ähnliche erinnerungen in den
familien gibt weil fast jede familie
hier jemanden im krieg belassen
mir als deutsche sagt man hier immer
wenn ich den russen zum sieges tag
gratuliere und auch sagen dass wir
dankbar sind dass wir befreit worden
sind
dann höre ich ganz offen das habe ich
heute morgen jetzt wieder von einem
taxifahrer gehört mit dem ich ins studio
gefahren bin
er hat mir gesagt alles gut möge es nie
wieder krieg geben
wir verabschieden uns jetzt wir
verabschieden uns jetzt hier von ihnen
mit diesen letzten bildern der parade es
wird jetzt gleich corona nachgehakt
gezeigt mit michael krons phoenix und
wenn sie dran bleiben dann um 10 45 sind
wir live beim spd-parteitag tschüss aus
dem studium moskau
[Musik]
corona nachgehakt was wir bisher wissen
meine damen und herren im corona
nachgehakt